[Music]
we have decided that because the
horrible evil greedy rich people are
everywhere that
james our producer decided we're going
to start exposing
how horrible and greedy and evil they
are
pretty regular basis
so carissa collins is the owner of the
popular instagram account the collins
kids which consists of her and her nine
children the social media influencer
revealed on tuesday
that this guy with a 400 million dollar
net worth he's kind of a short guy
and um james no george campbell no the
guy the guy with the 400 million net
worth that would not be james and that
would not be george campbell oh that's
my bad yeah his name is shaq she might
have heard of him it's a cute little
deal never heard of him yeah so
he took the collins family out to dinner
babes chicken
the next day took him the mercedes-benz
dealer and bought them a 15 passenger
band
after buying the car they'd went out to
dinner again at the rainforest cafe
where he dropped another thousand bucks
with the tip on the waitress just the
tip to the waitress alone
and after dinner he uh noticed uh
chris's husband's truck which was uh the
heat and air and the air conditioning
was falling apart the you know it was a
dumpy truck and so he took him down the
ford dealership and bought him a new
truck
who is shaq did you know i could see
like elvis i get choked up cars i get
choked up on these things man this is
amazing
cause
let's not blow pat that a thousand
dollars for that waitress at the
rainforest cafe changed her
entire i mean
that's huge yeah don't drive past a 15
passenger mercedes van okay that's just
a little different than a thousand
dollars too but oh my god oh and i saw
this one where he got up all of this he
dropped less than i don't know what that
van cost but he dropped 150 000
probably
and he made he has a 400 million net
worth so that is
like you know it's a very very small
percentage ratio of his world he's not
broke from doing it
i saw this one the guy was in there and
he was trying to buy a wedding i mean
engagement ring for his wife and check
just happened to be in the same jewelry
store shopping for something
and the guy was kind of getting nervous
and he was trying to he was paying and
shaq walked over and just handed his car
to the the person at the counter and pat
him on the back and said congratulations
my man can you imagine being able to
just do that for somebody just being in
there to buy something for your wife or
your sister and all of a sudden be able
to
i mean come on man it was such an
amazing thing
bought a house for this young man who
was paralyzed by a stray bullet
yeah these evil rich people need to stop
this that is ridiculous that's just
ridiculous that your your evilness needs
to stop that's right
evilness that's a word right
evil in action
check you're just you're destroying the
reputation of the evil rich people come
on man with that with that outrageous
generosity come on man
wow that's pretty cool i did not know he
had this
uh knack for random
generosity like this that's very well
played but a thousand places and he's so
he's so subtle because he fills up the
whole room when he walks in it so it's
no way but there's no way you can be
shaq and be
invisible but can i tell you he does it
i saw him i saw a clip of this with the
guy at the zales and it was the most
quiet it wasn't a big hey look what i'm
doing he gently handed the guy and said
this one's on me and it's in his big
deep voice and he pat the guy on the
back and he said congratulations brother
and walked off it was not a
it was i've been blessed so i can be a
blessing right it's that sense of i've
been given so much and i'm just gonna
bless these families and and of course
he's got these big you know things that
he gives 500 kids clothes here but
but it's just that kind of generosity
man that i can get choked up thinking
about it because it's so cool
um and thinking how cool would be on the
other end of this to be able to just do
that well the thing is with our you know
generous people make your eyes leak yeah
and they just we all love them nobody
hate nobody hates generous people no
but but you know you can't do that
if you're broke
if you're broke
and you're bitching about rich people on
your iphone that you have payments on
you can't do that cause you're broke
so hello
just just just a little
heads up there
you know bitching about rich people on
your 800 dollar iphone thanks for
pulling the wool back thousand dollar
iphone huge yeah james you just you just
you're just showing people how rich
people really are um
continue this level of expose
it's just emotionally distressing to
you know to just let people see how
people really are out there
because
generosity is all over the place man